bachelor news now because there's plenty
of it starting with the bachelor Beauty
gone country I'm getting into music soon
it's like rock country pop I feel like
you could be a pop star I'm already a
pop star Corinne made a name for herself
as the sassy breakout star from Nick
vile season who's stupid now
now the 27 year old is breaking news to
et about her music plans telling us to
expect her first single late this year
meantime would newly single Ryan
Seacrest ever be the bachelor we asked
and he didn't rule it out I like
watching it but yeah I think I'm better
as a spectator we're gonna be being the
bachelor but enough and here's another
exclusive for you bachelor nation only
et was there as current Bachelorette
Hannah B brought her boys to Rhode
Island for tonight's group date
I want blood I came to play oh yeah I'll
be very surprised if nobody gets injured
today whatever alert
someone does that's Kevin being carted
off in an ambulance
back on the field we spotted Hannah
flirting with one of her most
talked-about front runners
Buki I really like leafy and I am
excited about getting to know more about
him I think it's important to show
Hannah that I'm willing to fight for her
in this relationship another one of
Hannah's main men Connor
ass Connor is great he is obviously very
heated so but he is so sweet really like
Connor what connects you to what do you
have in common so we both hate mints and
chocolates mixed together very specific
Connor I'm or cement life qualities
[Music]
[Applause]